الشركه ابل تطلق مؤتمرها السنويه العالمي
للمطورين والذي يستمر حتى التاسع من يونيو
مزبوط الشركه الامريكيه اعلنت عن نظام
ايفون جديد ios 17 يشمل عدد من المميزات
الجديده والتحسينات للهاتف ولحق يلي بتلحق
مسك الختام في المؤتمر هي نظاره الواقع
المعزز الجديده فيجن برو طبعا هذه النظاره
مدمجه بنظام صوتي محيطي تستطيع من خلالها
تشغيل مختلف التطبيقات واجراء مكالمات
الفيديو وحتى مشاهده الافلام والاوامر
بحركه العين والصوت واليدين ستكون النظاره
متاحه بدءا من العام المقبل ويبلغ سعرها
نحو
3,500 دولار
امريكي فقط لا غير
[موسيقى]
من كاليفورنيا ينضم الينا الخبير التقني
عبد الله السبع عبد الله مساك الله بالخير
بتوقيتك صبحك الله بالخير بتوقيتنا والله
يعينك على ايش راح تجيب لي معاك صوغه
قبل لا تنطرح كل شاكر لك عبد الله يعني
النظاره من
عبد الله هل احنا لما نقول ابل اطلقت
نظاره هل هي نظاره بمعنى انه احنا قاعد
ننتقص من هذا الشيء اللي ابل
عملتها وبالتالي هي اكبر من ان تكون نظاره
خلينا نقول لك ان هي اكبر من ان تكون
نظاره حسب المصطلح اللي انت قلت عليه نقدر
نقول عنها شيء مثل الكمبيوتر قاب
بالارتداء وتقدر تستخدم برامج الكمبيوتر
اللي انت معتاد عليها لكن انت ما انت
محدود بشاشه معينه مثلا الكمبيوترات
شاشاتها 15 13 17 انش لكن النظاره هذه راح
تقدر تستخدم المساحه اللي حولك بالتطبيقات
اللي انت تبغاها فعلى سبيل المثال جهه
اليمين تقدر تخلي عندك مثلا
قدامك تطبيق الصور يمين عندك الرسائل وراك
مثلا مسلسل فيلم انت حاب تشوفه في اي جهه
تحرك فيها راسك انت قادر تشوف المحتوى هذا
وقادر انك تتفاعل معاه الرهيب انه لنفترض
انك انت حابه تشوف مثلا مسلسل او فيلم
قادر انك توسع الشاشه حسب المساحه اللي
انت تحتاجها فلذلك في حال نج نظاره ابل
هذا سيشكل تهديد كبير لاجهزه الكمبيوتر
تهديد كبير لشاشات التلفزيون تهديد كبير
حتى لبعض الاجهزه اللي احنا معتادين عليها
لكن لازم نعرف معلومه وهي معلومه صراحه
جدا مهمه انه في شركات قبل اطلقت نظارات
واقع افتراضي واقع معزز لكن فشلت فشل ذريع
جدا ولم تستطع اقناع المستخدمين فنظاره
ابل الواقع الافتراضي ستكون طوق النجاه
لجميع الشركات التي تستثمر بشكل جدا كبير
في نظارات الواقع الافتراضي في حال ان ابل
ما قدرت تقنع المستخدمين انهم يستخدمون
هذه النظاره فللاسف الفشل راح يكون حليم
كل الشركات العامله في هذا المجال راح
نشوف في الايام القادمه مع انه يعني ابل
عندها قدره هائله على الاقناع على حسب ما
شفنا في السنوات الاخيره بس عبد الله هذا
بيذكرني بالجوجل كل اللي انعملوا بالتعاون
مع ريبان وكان في مشكله كبيره انطرحت في
تلك الفتره ويمكن عشان هيك لم تنتشر هذه
النظرات بشكل كبير موضوع الخصوصيه انه انت
بتقدر تاخذ صور وفيديوهات لاي شخص بدون ما
هو يكون عارف وبدون ما اكون قابل فهل هناك
مشكله في موضوع نظرات ابل بنفس الطريقه
وانا بصراحه بس قبل ما تجاوبني حبيت اعلق
انه يعني هذا راح يعمل راح يكون خطر على
اجهزه التلفزيون وراح يكون خطر على كثير
من الشركات مستقبلا وعلى اطفالنا لسا اكثر
خليهم ينعزلوا اكثر واكثر
طيب اول شيء النظاره ما هي موجهه للاطفال
فهي موجهه اساسا للمستخدمين حتى حجمها جدا
كبير فالاطفال غير قادرين على استخدامها
انما هي موجهه للبالغين على اساس يقدرون
يستخدمونها بشكل
صعبه شويه عليهم يعني المفترض انه ما تكون
وجهه يعني ما في احد عاقل يبي يشتري لطفل
مراهق اكيد نظاره بسعر 14 الف تقريبا او
15 الف يعني ف لان هي اساسا موجهه حاليا
للمطورين لكن نرجع لنظاره جوجل نظاره جوجل
فشلت بسبب انها اطلقت قبل وقتها ما كانت
التقنيات انها تساعدها انها تكون موجوده
انها تستمر مو فقط مشاكل خصوصيه وغيرها
انما التقنيات اللي اطلقت في ذيك الوقت ما
ساعدت نظاره انها ترى النور فهي تقنيه
اطلقت وقتها بشكل كبير فلذلك نظرت جوجل
عبد الله يعني ما ادري انا بروح اسرق من
الوقت قليلا لكن خليني اسال بانه ما ادري
اذا كان بالامكان انه جربتو هذه التقنيه
الجديده من ابل وبالتالي يعني انتم كنتوا
كعرب كثير موجودين في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
هل سيرافق اي او اس 17 او 17 ايضا تطويرات
على هذه النظاره وبالتالي ثغرات وغيره
مفصول بشكل كامل
النظاره نظام منفصل حتى متجر تطبيقات خاص
فيها تخيل انك انت قادر تدخل على النظاره
وتحمل تطبيقات خاص فيها لكن في تكامل ما
بين اجهزه المايك وما بين اجهزه الايفون
مع نظاره لكنه هذا نظام مفصول عن هذا
النظام زي النظام الخاص صاروا مفصل لكن هم
متكاملين بطريقه وباخرى بالتكامل ما بين
شكرا جزيلا عبد الله سبع الخبير التقني
كنت معنا من كاليفورنيا ان شاء الله رحله
سعيده الى الديار لمتابعه المزيد
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات